[Music]
on today's show we have a special
christmas eve show we talk about the
holiday stresses what you can do right
now to survive the holidays and also i
read the lyrics to my favorite metallica
christmas song say what stay tuned
[Music]
up on the house top reindeer is it pause
pause
dude this is the john dalony show the dr
john dolone show and it is christmas eve
what are you doing listening to this
podcast
here's my guess it's all falling apart
you are
taking a walk around your neighborhood
you got tears streaming down your face
cause all your family wants to talk
about is covid or
omicrons or whatever the food that you
got was terri whatever you didn't get
the gift you trying to put together a
trampoline and you and your husband hate
each other now whatever's going on it's
christmas eve
never fear kelly
james connor
and me we're here to help we're gonna
help you out we got the tactics for how
to get through tonight and the rest of
this christmas holiday we're gonna
support you this is a shorter special
christmas eve podcast just for you
and by the way if you want to go over to
the tubes and check out the blooper reel
we put up to the christmas blooper reel
it's pretty funny i got to see it today
i'm not very good at this job not very
good but
we're going to talk about a couple of
ways you can reduce holiday stress what
you can do right this second anything
you want to add james
no let's do it it's weird being here on
christmas eve
my kids are pretty bummed but if it's
for the greater good then i'm good with
it
let's go oh kelly's kids were like yeah
go to work mom that'd be great
[Laughter]
i have teenagers they don't care
[Laughter]
figures
robert your husband's sad to see you go
huh yeah because he has to be there with
them
[Laughter]
all right 13 ways to survive the
holidays are you ready let's do this
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john dolone's show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work and
time to go see somebody and it's way
across town what do i do because i want
help with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with betterhelp because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john daloni show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
all right here we go
so it's christmas eve and whatever
christmas is happening
is already happening
so here's your here's your goal number
one
picture what happens next and make that
happen
what does that mean that sounds stupid
and cheesy deloney listen
you can choose an environment where
nobody's fighting and that might mean
that you gotta take yourself out of it
that might mean that you have to tell
your teenagers if you speak again i'm
gonna set your hair on fire right don't
don't set your kids on fire but you have
to create a picture of what we want this
to look like it may be that the last
couple of days you had the in-laws show
up you had some weird cousins show up
um yeah was it cousin eddie showed up
and he's sitting outside they're sitting
outside everyone's complaining you get
up tomorrow morning and you say on
christmas we are having breakfast at 8
30. we're going to open presents at 10.
we are all going to go for a walk at 3.
i'm leaving at 5.
be very clear print off schedules
tonight and hand them to everybody this
isn't for discussion if you don't like
this you can go to another house for
christmas this is what christmas is
doing tomorrow but create a picture and
go do it all right the second one set
boundaries tell people we are not
talking about that
say those words
dad we're done talking about covet
mom
yep that's our president conversation's
over we're gonna talk about something
else
dad i like mark wahlberg you can stop
being so mean about him his muscles are
real and they're huge get over right
whatever the thing is mom i don't like
smashing pumpkins they're not good stop
talking about it whatever the thing is
okay
set boundaries i'm going to shower
nobody can come in here nobody can talk
to me nobody can whatever set the
boundaries
and by the way
if you're in a closet right now and
you're like whatever duluth what do you
have to lose your christmas eve already
is terrible
or if it's going great it's probably
because you have boundaries you have a
picture of christmas number three do
your best to avoid conflict if your
father-in-law says something and it's
like i think he's wrong just sit on it
just swallow it don't say anything it's
like nothing
or if your mom's like well i wouldn't
have done that with the stuffing why
don't you
just take it
just say nothing just say
nothing
why why have to comment back why start a
fight just stop avoid family conflict if
your cousin's going around asking
everybody for a thing like hey man can i
have
avoid the confidence avoid it all right
number four focus on what you can
control you cannot make that cousin who
chews loud chew less loud
you can't you can sit next to him in
stew and be crazy and be angry and be
frustrated or you can move
or you can choose just to fast through
that part of the meal
or you can put headphones whatever the
thing is focus on what you can control
and not what you can't control
if you have a house full of people that
you invited because you didn't have
boundaries three weeks ago or four weeks
ago they're there don't resent them
start having fun go buy bags of jumbo
marshmallows and just start pegging
people with them pass out the beers and
let's get this thing going get the
delony cards and just get off the rails
with stuff you want to get weird let's
get weird family but we're here right
focus on what you can control and let
the rest of the stuff go okay know your
role in the situation if you are at your
in-laws house shut your mouth nobody
cares what you think
if you are a husband that your wife's
parents house
stop talk don't say anything say no
words say no word just watch some
football game or a hunting show or stare
off into space go for a walk rake the
yard say nothing and vice versa
just know your role in the situation
if you're like the kid
oh my gosh for sure say nothing just go
around and hug people if that's what
your family does i don't know know your
role number six say no everybody say it
if you're putting together like a
stroller or some weird foosball table or
something right now and it's christmas
eve and you're just angry i want you
just to practice
no just say
say it say it
just no
so tomorrow they'll be like
oh let's go drive around the
neighborhood i thought we were gonna
you'd be like no
oh i drove all this way i thought you
loved me no
that'd be awesome if you said that don't
say that i think you probably still love
him
but just say no if you don't want to go
say no i don't i don't want to go
tonight um maybe in the morning
let's go out and have a big breakfast i
want a big breakfast no thank you y'all
are welcome to go but i'm going to stay
here just say no i can't say no i can't
you can
you choose not to say no say no
no
oh my gosh that was incredible way to go
james
that's james's middle name by the way he
has the word no tattooed on his chest
all right number and yes he did show us
all of us a lot number seven limit your
time on social media don't all sit on a
couch staring at your phones
there's nothing worse than being a
miserable
christmas
situation and everyone is just looking
at everyone else's christmas fantasies
or just sitting at home alone man
christmas is hard for a lot of people
you have no families to go to you're
just working
and you get home and it's just a regular
old night like every other night and
you're throwing something in the
microwave because you're tired and
you're exhausted
don't run to social media
don't run social media it's gonna make
every feeling you have
amplified it's gonna make it bigger it's
gonna make it harder it's gonna hurt
don't do it take a day off take a couple
of days off social media okay
um number nine
don't overdo it on the sugar you'll
collapse everything in your body
do have that one night of pie whatever
get it get it
work out beforehand fast beforehand have
a plan for afterwards uh peter tia talks
about man he makes sure everybody's
taking leftovers with them i have to do
that too because i have no self-control
i've got no self could after after we
have our one big feast that sweet's got
to go cause i'll graze on them like
cattle like an old cow i'll just sit
there all day grazing
don't overdo it on the sugar don't
overdo it on the sugar
10 get plenty of sleep the temptation is
to stay up get up super early to not go
to bed we haven't talked all year so we
need to talk to a four a.m and then the
rest of the week's gonna be a disaster
go to bed
go to bed and get some sleep stay
healthy if you exercise regularly keep
exercising if normally you go for runs
take your family on walks whatever it
looks like but keep moving your body
take 30 minutes or an hour to work out
so that you can show up for the rest of
the time with your family if this is
just another day in your life
you keep hitting the gym too
number 11
protect your downtime take breaks from
other people
naps are okay
i'm gonna read my new book
alone everybody leave me alone i'm going
for a walk by myself i'm gonna go around
and go fishing for the afternoon alone
whatever that looks like for you protect
your downtime that may be stuff you can
double dip on when it comes to sleep or
working out whatever
number 12
instead of
being advice guy or advice gal all the
time
ask good questions
ask questions
instead of when your granddad says i
think i think it's a buncha but
say granddad what was the time when you
were younger and things were just scary
ask that question
or i think these kids these days aren't
wearing enough clothes i don't they need
to put some clothes on all their body
parts are poking out everywhere
hey grandad what was like when you first
saw grandmother
dude
she was
smoking she was beautiful
like tell me about that
right ask good questions don't get into
debates and discussions and fights back
to the top about avoid family conflict
you can often avoid family conflict by
asking really good questions
last one
make connection your number one priority
now
that may mean that you got to go spend
some time with people who aren't your
family that may mean you're one of the
millions of millions upon millions of
people who are stuck at home by
themselves
they don't have any family they're not
opening any presents tomorrow they had
to get themselves a present
christmas is heartbreaking reminds you
of a loss
somebody has passed away recently that
you missed somebody's broke up with you
that you miss
reach out to other people not through
social media but through
human connection what does that mean
it's christmas eve tomorrow
get on the phone and get four or five
people over to your house have an
impromptu gift exchange do something fun
write each other poems sing songs
whatever the thing is watch an old movie
die hard a great christmas movie
whatever watch the show do something
connect with people
connect with people
find a way that you can peel your
grandmother off the rest of the group
and you can just go for a walk
say how's the last year been been hard
huh
what's it like
get on facetime and talk to your cousins
that you haven't seen in a while
connect connect connect
cool that's the way and don't drink too
much
drinking and family events usually end
up in
domestic disputes don't do it don't do
it and don't drink with kelly that
always ends
so not good
all right so i hope that helps hope that
helps we'll be right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe cause you got an expert in a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in the mls consumer access dot org
equal housing lender 1749 mallory lane
sweet 100 brentwood tennessee 37027
programs are for select loan types only
and are not available in all states or
locations
all right we're back so merry christmas
we love you so so grateful for you that
you spend time with us you give us the
most precious resource on planet earth
your time as we wrap up today's show i'm
gonna give you the lyrics to my favorite
christmas song of all time
it's a song about our families
about
the holidays
just about life
soft the black album by metallica and
the song is sad but true
and it goes like this
hey
i'm your life i'm the one who takes you
there
hey i'm your life i'm the one who cares
they betray i'm your only true friend
now
they'll betray i'm forever there
this talk's about drugs
i'm your dream make you real i'm your
eyes and you must steal i'm your pain
when you can't feel
sad but true
i'm your dream mind astray i'm your eyes
while you're away i'm your pain while
you repay you know
it's sad but true
you know it's sad but true
like my career
and my body composition
merry christmas we'll see you soon on
the dr john lennon show